Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is 2192. David P Here is a
really good question about the Fox News
text message scandal. Listen to this.
Speaker 2: Hey, David, I just want to speak
really briefly about the Fox News scandal.
I know that you've been covering it really
well, but I just have a comment. You know,
I think that all of this stuff that's coming
out in general simply won't have as big of an
impact because the people that watch Fox
News will never see it. In other words,
the reason they haven't settled, which most
people are like, why haven't they settled?
This is very damaging to them because they
settle. They have to say to their audience,
Listen, we lied to you and they probably have
to say it a hundred times a day. But the point
is that they make more money doing it and they
know this. Therefore, why would they settle?
They'll lose 1.6 billion. It will hurt them.
Speaker 1: So here's the thing. The caller
is correct that a lot. You know, we
asked yesterday and the day before.
Are Tucker's viewers going to abandon Tucker
Because they're MAGA people and they watch
Tucker with the idea that Trump's going to be
praised by Tucker. And now Tucker is exposed in
text messages saying he hates Trump passionately.
Tucker's viewers just won't even hear about that
story because Fox News isn't covering the story
and they only watch Fox News. But there's another
aspect to this. Even if the caller is right that
if Fox were to settle, they might have to do a
mea culpa and say we were wrong. We lied about
this and that. I don't even think their followers
would care about that. I genuinely don't. I think
they'd go. The liberal media forced them to do it.
The liberal establishment forced them to do it.
They didn't really lie. They told the truth. So
I actually think the caller is wrong in that
particular sense. Let me know what you think.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Sign up at join Pacman dot com. Don't miss it.